[Music]
hey what's up MKBHD here so have you
ever wondered how much longer it would
take to do a road trip in an electric
car versus a gas car in 2021 and does it
matter which type of electric car you
take
it's an interesting question I'm sure
many of us have wondered this and most
reasonable people would probably stop
there but not me nope nope my team and I
decided to actually find the real answer
by really doing it and running it like a
sort of a scientific experiment so you
know it's one thing to go by the numbers
on paper which we all have and the
Chargers on the map which we can all
look at but it's another thing
to actually go do it but we're just
gonna find out we're gonna do this uh
the hard way by actually going on a
massive road trip with
gas cars and electric cars to actually
put this to the test so it's it's a
little bit unscientific but we've got a
set of rules and we've got a route we're
going to take to make it happen so
here are the cars first we have Tesla
Model S plaid you're probably familiar
I've already done videos about this car
with the 21 inch wheels on it right here
it has a 350 mile range on 100 battery
next to it here we've got
Ford Mustang Mach e California Route 1
Edition has about a 305 mile range
charges out Electrify America Chargers
and then last but not least we have a
gas car control this is what's going to
make the results of the test I think
pretty interesting so we've got an Audi
Q5 here on a full tank of gas it'll get
about
460 miles of range and uh we're gonna
start them all from the same place at
the same time there happens to be a spot
near our studio with a gas station a
Tesla Supercharger and Electrify America
charger we're going to leave with a full
tank and a full battery all at the same
time from there we're going to do a
route
that hits uh Ithaca New York Lake Placid
New York Niagara Falls Scranton
Pennsylvania we're going to do this
whole circle you've probably already
seen a lot of this on Twitter by the
time this video goes up but we've got
members we got the whole team most of
the team here we're going to be in these
cars probably trash talking a little bit
and turning into a bit of a race but to
see exactly how much time charging at
these different infrastructures adds to
a road trip so
mile one of a thousand starts now so
yeah that's it pretty simple the goal
just treat it like a normal road trip
you're obviously trying to go around the
loop as fast as possible but two rules
one no speeding we have a hard cap limit
to our speed for all the cars that's the
same but two uh just hit all the
waypoints just get all the pictures we
want out of all those different
waypoints until you do the Thousand
Miles we added an overnight break for
sanity so we have a hotel in Niagara
Falls to break the trip into two days
but everyone wakes up on the second day
with the same state of charge that they
want to sleep with and we'll add up all
the time Deltas at the end so at this
point you know the route you know the
cars go ahead and guess how you think it
went go ahead and guess what you think
happened what order did the cars come in
and how far apart did they finish the
Thousand Miles now go ahead and tell you
right off the bat your guess about the
order of the cars the way they finish
one two three
probably correct your guess about how
far apart they finished
probably wrong so we're putting together
a whole video on this road trip
experience on the studio channel so if
you want all the details and every
single thing that happened at each stop
to each team if you want to go on the
road trip with us go ahead and hit the
Subscribe button to the studio channel
to see that when it comes out but this
video is the breakdown of exactly what
happened so the gas car the gas car had
the most predictable trip right so they
stopped for five minutes for a break and
gas on the way up to Lake Placid got
there in 4 hours 49 minutes then they
took two short breaks on the way to
Niagara Falls one was 20 minutes for
food and then the other was 10 minutes
for gas and using the bathroom that was
their day one they arrived at Niagara
Falls at 11 hours 8 minutes so then the
Tesla trip took off at the same time
right off the bat it gets interesting I
was driving and I decided to be kind of
bold and go all the way from the
starting point to Lake Placid up those
mountains on one charge without stopping
we actually passed by the sign without
stopping to take a picture because our
battery was so low that we weren't sure
if we were going to make it but we did
make it to the top and there's a
supercharger up there I had one mile
remaining on the battery but that was
our first stop for half an hour where we
got some snacks we got passed by the gas
car but then we doubled back a bit to
take a photo of the sign and then headed
over to Niagara Falls and we stopped two
more times to charge on the way once for
46 minutes were actually filled up the
battery and another quick eight minute
stop for safety before arriving at
Niagara Falls with about 70 miles left
on the battery in almost exactly 12
hours then the Mustang Maki okay so they
headed up towards Lake Placid along with
the Tesla again at the same time but
with the smallest Range they had to pull
off first and the car routed them to an
evolved New York charger that was out of
order so with 36 miles on the battery
they had no choice but to head the wrong
direction into Vermont to the nearest
available charger there they had to sit
for almost two hours before they left
with enough battery and at this point
they had gone so far out of the way and
they're so far behind that they just
decided they could just skip Lake Placid
just to make it to Niagara before the
end of the day so that's what they did
they skipped it and went straight across
West they hit one more charger for 41
minutes which brought them to near 80
battery then at 9 30 they arrived at
another charger stop
that was also broken so they navigated
for another half hour to find another
charger this turned out to be a barely
working trickle charger where it only
added two percent to their battery so
they drove another half hour
precariously to an Electrify America
charger where they arrived at five
percent left and this one worked
perfectly for 46 minutes which gave them
enough juice to finally get to Niagara
Falls by 12 40 in the morning after 16
hours and 40 minutes on the road that's
about five hours behind the gas car so
that first leg taught us a lot so we're
sitting about 650 miles in at this point
the gas cars you probably predicted is
in first place the Tesla as you may have
also predicted is in second it's about
half an hour behind after this first leg
and the Maki in third is now about five
hours behind so I mean we've seen we've
seen we've read the articles before of
horror stories of charging trying to do
a road trip in a Porsche Thai can
getting to a broken charger and all
we've seen that online in the past but
now that it's happening to this team as
we're doing it it's a whole other thing
to actually live through it and actually
both the the members of that Maki team
are EV drivers now in an attempt to even
it out a bit on the second day uh the
the gas car in the Tesla wouldn't really
change much but team mock e would Now
operate under their Newfound knowledge
that the in-car navigation on the Ford
could not be trusted so they would be
using their own apps they would be
essentially trying to only hit Electrify
America chargers for this leg of the
trip ignore what the car tells you to
navigate to ignore the Ford approved
stops because that clearly didn't work
last time they're just going to do it on
their own more advanced way
and that shocker went much better so all
cars took off at the same time again and
the gas car went straight to the Cornell
clock then after that photo they took a
short 10 minute gas stop and then an
hour later took another quick 10 minute
food break didn't even add gas during
that stop just stopped to eat then it
went straight to Scranton for the paper
building photo then all the way to the
Finish no range concerns at all no
problem this second leg took them 7
hours 51 minutes so the Tesla the Tesla
arrived at Niagara with pretty low
battery 70 miles left so we actually
started off going right to a charging
stop at Cheektowaga 15 minute stop there
then we drove to another supercharger at
Ithaca for 25 more minutes of charging
then from there we got the Ithaca photo
and then went all the way down to
Scranton took that photo and then took
one last charging and food stop at
Bartonsville which gave us plenty more
than enough to get home in our total
which was eight hours which was pretty
impressively less than an hour behind
the gas car again then the Machi with
their Newfound confidence in only using
Electrify America Chargers this time had
a much better time today so they went to
Waterloo for their first charge where
the first charger didn't work but the
second one did and they charged for 32
minutes here then they got to Ithaca
took their Cornell photo then they drove
to Scranton with one brief coffee break
in the middle
then nearby stopped at another EA
charger where three of the four Chargers
didn't work but the last one did so they
charged there for 32 minutes and made
their way back to the studio just about
half an hour behind the Tesla so for a
total of 8 hours 49 minutes so the order
was still the same but the day two
Deltas were a bit smaller so I'd say I
learned a few things from this whole
Thousand Mile Road Trip actually things
that we we kind of already knew but that
are much more crystallized now that
we've gone through it now to answer the
question straight from the beginning how
much time does switching to Electric
actually add to the road trip first of
all I want to acknowledge that there are
plenty of different variables that could
contribute to some of the Deltas not
only could I have used a different car
or different wheels for a different
range on each of them but there are also
things like different traffic different
amounts of time taking photos at the
waypoints different navigation routes
and habits and things like that so I'm
gonna I'm just gonna give like a plus or
minus 10 percent
Delta just on how long these things took
so at the end we got the Tesla added one
hour 32 minutes
per thousand miles of road tripping it's
really not bad and the Mustang Maki
added 7 hours and 32 minutes although
six and a half hours of that was on the
first day and then it was an hour and
three minutes on day two so I think it's
safe to say that if you do a lot of road
trips uh the Tesla Road Trip experience
is currently pretty far ahead of any
other electric car especially here where
we did the test in the U.S but not for
the reason you might be thinking like
there's a couple variables in here and
part of it is the slightly longer range
of the car sure and part of it is the
supercharger Network versus the other
networks used by the Machi sure but the
biggest thing that contributed to our
results was the accuracy of the
information displayed in the car so for
range differences it's actually
interesting it seems like the Tesla goes
by the max EPA estimated rating they can
possibly quote which is mostly based on
highway driving and there's even some
other official ratings in Europe there's
a wltp rating which has different ratios
of City mixed in with Highway there's
another called nedc but generally I've
found that achieving Tesla's quoted
range would require pretty much perfect
conditions perfect weather perfect
temperature outside perfect roads
perfect traffic not driving too fast you
pretty much never get it perfect so the
Plaid model less that I've been driving
that we use for this test has a full
battery rating of 345 miles on those
Wheels it's right between the long range
model 3 and Long Range model y but I
would never ever attempt to try to reach
a charger 345 miles away because as
you're driving you can see the range
dropping off of the battery faster than
you're covering them on the road matter
of fact on the first leg of that trip we
just did we went from the studio up to
Lake Placid that went from 345 miles
full battery all the way down to one
mile left when we pulled in 0.3 percent
battery
and that was only a 293 mile trip so
that's a 15 difference between the range
you're quoted on paper with perfect
conditions and what we actually got and
I feel like all Tesla owners I know have
really started to calibrate for this
like if your car says you have 40 miles
left you better get to a charger in the
next 30 miles or so like that's just the
way it is especially in Winter or if
it's particularly cold You know despite
the new heat pump it doesn't take zero
energy to get the battery to the
temperature it likes so that's just the
Tesla range and efficiency Factor now
the Mustang Mach e on the other hand
very very consistent with the number
being displayed on the dash and the
range you actually got it actually
consistently outperformed that number
just a little bit which leads me to
believe Ford isn't quoting the maximum
EPA rated range possible and we found
this to be true of some other electric
cars too the Porsche taikan is one that
actually consistently way outperforms
its quoted range by a pretty big margin
and you might remember also Ford told me
their F-150 Lightning their quoted range
will be with a thousand pounds of cargo
in the trunk so it may even go further
when it's empty so these are all
different ways of going about quoted
range but I think the general philosophy
you're seeing with the Fords and
Porsches of the world is under promise
over deliver just so your customer
doesn't have to worry too much about the
range that they say they're going to get
in the car but here's the the crazy part
of all this is Tesla Model S plaid on
those 21s 345 miles of quoted range Ford
Mustang Mach e California Route 1
Edition 305 miles of coated range
I would expect those cars to go about
the same distance some to think about so
the Tesla may have a bit more range
sometimes but that clearly doesn't make
nearly as much of a difference as the
infrastructure or the charging Network
to fast charge and go on road trips now
if you don't go on road trips that much
none of this may really matter to you
and your ownership experience and that's
fine but if you do the Tesla
Supercharger network is built and owned
by Tesla and it's built to the exact
spec of their cars works great with them
and then there's every other EV and all
the other public charging networks that
kind of all have somewhat variable
experiences I kind of think of it a
little bit like lightning versus USB
type c so right now today there are
about 1100 Tesla Supercharger stations
in the US and they're mostly along major
roads either at rest stops or in mall
parking lots around food things like
that and then with the mock e you will
use the fordpass charging Network and if
you look on Ford's website for the Maki
it says that that's the large just
public charging Network in North America
offered by a car manufacturer which is
it feels like they're trying to Loop in
a couple different things there to make
that statement true they definitely want
to be able to say they've got the
biggest network but it's a public
network too and it's clearly it's not
built by Ford and so the Ford pass
network is looping in a bunch of
different other public charging networks
into one it streamlines the payment
experience so you only need one forward
pass account it's convenient for the
buyer but that includes about 600
Electrify America super fast Chargers
some of them up to 350 kilowatts when
the car supports it that's amazing but
that also includes some slow Chargers
some offline Chargers some out of order
broken Chargers and that's the
difference and because these Chargers
aren't built by Ford they aren't managed
directly by Ford there's a bit of a
communication gap between when one of
them might go down and that info Nation
actually showing up to the driver in the
car usually doesn't know until he gets
there so the difference is literally
when I sit down to plan a road trip in
the Tesla on the screen I'm getting all
of my information this is what they've
done so well with their software it's
telling me whether or not I can make it
to my destination on one charge if I
can't it's going to route me through
superchargers along the way it tells me
how long I need to charge at the
supercharger to continue my trip and how
much battery it'll leave me with when I
arrive but even better yet for each
charger it tells me how many stalls
there are the speed of the Chargers how
many are out of order and how many are
literally currently being occupied by
other cars charging right now Ford is
able to tell you about as much as they
know but they often don't know if there
are charges that are down or broken or
offline or something which is what
happened during our trip the trip in the
car navigated them to a charger that was
offline I think it was for maintenance
it was being updated or something but
that would have been really really bad
if they'd arrived there with like one
mile of battery left like I did when I
arrived at Lake Placid knowing trusting
that the superchargers would be there
and working that's the difference I
could really trust what was being shown
in the car and when I arrived there I'd
have charges available and that's just
not the case in the Ford so I kind of
felt like if lightning is the Tesla
Supercharger Network it's tightly
controlled by Apple the same way the
Tesla Supercharger network is tightly
controlled and you have the vertical
integration and that helps the
experience but then on the other side
there's USB type c a more open standard
kind of like CCS which is the charger
but like there's some that are faster
there are some that are slower and
there's a whole mix in between so it's
just I'm getting in the weeds but that's
what it reminded me of but then last FAQ
I know we were wondering what's the cost
difference actually between these two
trips electricity is typically cheaper
than gas after all but how much cheaper
so I wrote this down all the cars
started from roughly 100 like we said
leaving that initial stop the gas car
spent
84.79 during their their trip just on
gas the Tesla which had free
supercharging credit but I went back and
calculated how much it would have cost
66.35 and then the Mach e same idea we
had forward pass charging credit but we
used about
61.25 of that credit so they all charge
per kilowatt it was something around 30
to 35 cents per kilowatt so overall
take from this what you will you you
might not be someone who does road trips
like I said and a big part of the
electric car owning experience is like
starting every day with 100 battery in
your garage that's a totally different
part of this but if you do a lot of
people do frequent road trips maybe an
annual road trip maybe even more than
that then you start to think about this
stuff and the situation is also
constantly changing we're constantly
going to be getting faster and faster
Chargers we're going to get more
Chargers all over the world we're also
going to get longer and longer ranges in
these EVs and so I'd be curious if we
did another one of these tests in a year
or two how it would fare you know the
4680 batteries are around the corner
allegedly for some of these cars so
we'll see but again if you want to see
how this entire experience actually went
if you want to feel like you're going
along the road trip with us Studio
Channel link below is where you should
go for that but in the meantime I'm
curious now that you've seen this now
that you know
I want to know what you think your next
car purchase will be do you think it
will be a gas car or an electric car
we'll use the comment section as like a
polling if you want to tell us why let
me know why but if you think your next
car whenever that is will be gas for
electric all right that's been it thanks
for watching this experiment talk to you
guys in the next one peace
[Music]